I just finished my round two game from
Buell and this was a long one it was I
think just about five hours and I
finished maybe half hour ago it is 7 36
p.m so I'm kind of tired round started
at 2PM but I'll try and power through
this
I was playing a pretty young player uh
by the name of severe Molly and he is I
think 13 years old maybe 14 but young
and definitely underrated player uh his
current feed-day rating is 2094.
and coming into this game I couldn't
actually find too many of his games in
the database couldn't find his online
accounts
um but I found enough recent games to
know that he plays a slav defense
and that was basically all I needed to
decide my opening beforehand and I
actually decided to play a line that
I've never played before
um first of all I very rarely play the
Queen's gambits I usually like to play
London if I go for D4 on move one but
the reason why I went for Queen's Gambit
was in this position I had remembered a
very tricky line that I had seen maybe
about three years ago it was actually
during a collaboration with Grand Master
Iman Hamilton of Chess bra and we had
maybe a two or three hour collab where
we were just going through like cool
tricky opening ideas and he showed me a
cool idea against the slav which I
figured I would try in this game now it
starts with a somewhat off-beat move
this move Knight to D2 I should mention
that white can start with Knight F3 and
then later play 92 but the point is
after Knight F6 Knight F3 Bishop F5 it
looks like a very normal slav but white
has delayed this move Pawn to E3 for a
very tricky reason now in this game my
opponent didn't play Bishop F5 and we'll
we'll get to what he did play but
there's a really cool trap here which I
want to show that Amman had shown me
years ago is white can play Knight H4
and after the natural Bishop to G6
there's Queen to B3 hitting B7 and let
me just show the database here the most
played move is Queen B6 which is usually
the most natural move to defend B7 but
after Queen B6 there's a really cool
idea for white to get the advantage and
if you want to try and find it feel free
to pause the video and what I'll
probably do is link the collab uh with
Amman somewhere maybe down below
because uh actually before the game
today I was re-watching the collab and
uh when Amman showed me the next move
for white I said wow maybe at least once
maybe twice maybe three times
some sort of like Knight H4 Bishop here
and you oh you end up threatening oh
that's so nice oh wow wow but uh the wow
move is Queen H3
with the double idea of first of all
taking the bishop and having the pin
against each Pawn so that would force F
takes G6 but there's another idea of
Queen C8
so if Fox not careful and takes on D4
Queen C8 is checkmates
and there's other lines where Queen CH
forces Queen d8 and then Queen takes B7
um and white is already much much better
here
so I told my opponent this after the
game and then he told me that he
actually fell for this trap before so
um I didn't know that but it was
interesting tidbits that he was aware of
this idea and that was the reason why he
didn't play Bishop F5
um now I do want to note Bishop F5 is a
perfectly fine move and after Knight H4
uh the best move for black is Bishop E4
and there's a lot of uh sharp lines that
can emerge from this position which
maybe I'll I'll save for another day to
share uh but let me show what happened
in this game instead of Bishop F5 he
played the move pawned E6
and um yeah I'm hiding notation to avoid
spoilers so after upon E6 uh it's a
little bit passive for black because now
the bishop on C8 is a bit stuck and here
I just continue with uh with a Catalan
setup I go for G3
and after Knight D7 Bishop G2 next
several moves were very natural
developing moves
and um yeah I was pretty happy with
opening given that it's super super
solid for whites and I don't have to
worry about like the shark Catalan lines
where black can take and try and defend
because my knight is already defending
the pawn on C4 so here I continue being
solid Queen C2 uh I had the vision in
mind of eventually playing like B3 and
Bishop B2 Rook D1 and if black kind of
waits around uh the long-term idea for
white is to get this E4 break
um but he went for a more kind of direct
plan starting with rookie eight and
after B3 he played Pawn T5
so already a lot of tension in the
center now I didn't mind this move
because I'm able to take on D5
and
it's actually a nice transformation for
whites at least I think it's a nice
transformation because after he takes
back I take on E5 and then black is left
with this basically Queen's Pawn which
can be a long-term liability I do want
to mention that if he tries to move E4
here then there's a nice line I can take
on C6 counter-attacking the knights and
after takes takes my Pawn is a bit
further and this is just bad for black
so we got to this position and now I'm
playing against the iqp on D5 I start
with Bishop to B2 he plays Knight C6 I
play Pawn E3 uh Knight C6 did unleash
the Rook so I didn't want to mess with
uh The Rook potentially taking the
e-pawn and a very common idea in these
sort of positions where the point has
like so Queen's Pawn it's usually very
important to control the square directly
in front of the Pod this is my
blockading square and I'm controlling it
with my e-pawn my Knights and my bishop
and if I can control the block heating
Square then black can basically never
liquidate and then later my plan is to
put a rook on D1 and eventually put more
pieces to attack the pawn
so from here he plays Knight B4 which
was a little bit surprising because I
just go back to B1 and after 94 I kick
his Knight so it seemed like he lost a
little bit of time but then he surprised
me again with this move Knight A6 is
expecting the Knight to go back to C6
but it was an interesting maneuver with
the idea of playing Knight C7 and then
being able to defend the pawn with the
Knights then maybe later than I can
activate via E6
so I continue with Pawn B4 and I was
very happy with this move because it
enables my Knights to get into play so
he plays Knight C7 I play Knight B3
Bishop F5 aligning with my queen now I
don't move my queen immediately I attack
the bishop on F5 and there's really no
tactics black can employ here to exploit
my queen because The Bishop's hanging if
he tries Knight takes G3 I would simply
take the bishop and this would be a very
good transformation for whites having
two minor pieces for rook and Pawn
uh so he moves back to G6 I play Queen
A2 he plays Rook C8 and I'm still
improving uh there's a lot of just
natural improving moves so the position
essentially played itself for a good
portion of this middle game uh and then
I play Knight H4 so hitting the bishop
on G6 but also eyeing that five square
for one of my Knights and here I was
dreaming of eventually Knight F5 and
then orchestrating some King side attack
especially if my queen goes to A1 I can
have up to three attackers against the
G7 Pawn on top of that I also have ideas
of Bishop H3 to just find a different
diagonal for the lights for a bishop and
kick away The Rook from C8 so at this
point I was feeling really comfortable
and I also had a nice time Advantage so
everything seemed to be going well but
he didn't crack easily he started with
Bishop H5 hitting the Rook I played Rook
to D3 in hindsight I maybe should have
considered this move F3 and I did take
time actually I took about 12 minutes
before playing Rook D3 and F3 was a
consideration I didn't go for it because
it just looks ugly it seems to weaken
the epon but it does get initiative and
um again perhaps the bishop can find a
different diagonal on each three
but after Rook D3 uh he plays Bishop to
f8 so he's just trying to hold his
ground and um and be as solid as
possible I play Rook 2 C1 so at this
point I'm thinking of playing Bishop H3
next to chase The Rook away from the C
file and then maybe Sunday uh get a
double up and pressure the Knight on C7
but here he plays Queen D7 which is a
useful move and it's a prophylactic move
because it prevents Bishop H3 uh slide
play Knight to F5 and I'm still trying
to just make all my pieces as happy as
possible
uh he plays Queen to B5
which caught me a little bit off guard I
wasn't expecting this move and I pretty
quickly played Bishop F1 thinking that
the queen is just misplaced on B5 but
then he plays Queen A4 and here I played
my next move relatively quickly with
just a few minutes of thinking Bishop to
H3
and it turns out that this move was
actually a big mistake and I will admit
I did look very briefly with engine
after the game so I am aware that this
move was not good but during the game I
still felt really uh really happy here
given that The Rook is now under
pressure and it's also tied down to
defending the Knight on C7 but then from
here he finds a series of just very very
strong and resourceful moves starting
with Knight T6
and this move is upon sacrifice because
it just abandons the D5 Pawn but I
realize it's not so simple for me to
just get away with winning the pawn on
D5 because if I take first on C8 he can
take and then if I take with Rook uh
there's a C2 Square which is quite
annoying either Rook C2 or queen C2 and
then I have issues with the F2 Pawn
and if I take with Queen I think it's a
similar story
um it just seems
like a mess here like there's Knight G5
to defend an attack and then Queen C2 so
I thought for a little bit and I tried
to just
be solid and not let him get too much
active play I played the move Queen to
A1 which I thought is nice a nice
multi-purpose move not only defending
the Rook so I'm not allowing him to just
take over the C file but I'm also
creating the battery with a bishop and
targeting the G7 Pawn but after I play
Queen A1 he found an incredibly strong
move which I completely overlooked this
move Rook to C2
and even though it seems like I still
have like good pieces and it seems like
everything should be under control uh
the big problem for white is this F2
Pawn it's actually a glaring weakness in
the position that can't easily be
defended
and after he played Rook C2 I realized
that white is under serious pressure
um if I try and play Rook F1 he has to
move Bishop E2 like all of a sudden
things are just crumbling for white
so while I played in the game was Rook
takes D5
essentially abandoning my F2 Pawn I
should note that if I take first on C2
he would take back and yeah there's no
good way for me to defend F2 uh given
that my queen is tied down to defending
the bishop
so yeah I took on D5 and then he finds
another strong move Queens of B3 which
hits my Bishop hits a rook essentially
forces me to take on C2 and after I take
back I still have no good way to defend
F2 and I saw this position coming from a
distance and I thought it's still
actually very complex because I have the
move Bishop to G2 allowing Queen F2 and
after King H1 uh it's still equal
material like we just had a trade of
Pawns basically uh D5 for F2 and it's
still a really really just crazy given
that it seems like white has a lot of
attacking potential on the king side but
black also has attacking potential given
that I just lost my F2 pawn and the
Knights bishop and queen are all
swarming around and to make matters even
more crazy we're both getting pretty low
on time and we're still well before move
um on move 40 we will get an extra 50
minutes
um but we have nine more moves to make
until the extra time is added
so at this point I I really had a hard
time uh processing what's going on in
the position I tried to take it move by
move uh he plays Knight to D2 here which
I think is another like very strong move
should note the Knight was attacked by
the bishop and it seems like Knight D2
is very risky given that the rook's
attacking it and he's just going very
deep into my territory uh but the point
is after I play Bishop C3 hitting the
knights he Maneuvers to C4 where now
black is pressuring the e-pawn and the a
pawn and it's actually quite annoying
for white to find a useful move in this
position
I wanted to explain the G7 Pawn but
black has enough Defenders and I really
wanted to play the move Knight H6 but
after takes takes it seems like a good
trade for white but then there's Knight
G5
and my Rook is just sandwiched on the
side of the board it's not the most
tasty sandwich for whites so I didn't go
for that
and then I spent a long time here trying
to figure out what to do uh spent four
minutes to play Queen E1 which was
somewhat of a panic move
um I think it turned out to be a very
big mistake because after he takes takes
there's a very strong move Pawn to G6
and it only gets worse here for whites
because after Knight to D4 black has
um just a more forcing moves Knight
takes E3 hitting my rook and my bishop
and I'm just living on the 30 second
increment now
I play Rook to D7 he takes on D4 I take
back and then Knight to C2 and at this
point I thought I'm just gonna resign
within like a move or two uh but that
didn't happen because I found uh at
least one
one ounce of Hope in the position is
this move Rook to E4
and the point is after takes takes takes
I did lose a piece I'm down uh down a
minor piece and a pawn but I thought
there's still maybe an outside chance
that things could get tricky given that
the Knight is a bit stuck on E1
but the problem for white is the night
is not trapped in order to win it I have
to attack it and I'm a couple moves away
uh with my king and that's a little bit
too slow
um because after Kim to G1 he found a
nice move Pawn to G5 and this was move
40 so we both got extra 50 minutes and
um I took some time here before playing
Knight F5 but I I did realize that the
position
um will take a miracle to uh to not lose
for lights because now he has Bishop to
F3 yeah I was just trying to create any
last chance I played Bishop to B1 he
played Bishop C6 and now he's creating
the square for the Knight on F3 and
after King F2 Knight F3 I think what
I'll do is zoom through the rest of the
game
um we'll see that I did try to at least
trade pawns uh my one hope was to trade
all all the remaining pawns and then
maybe make him uh display his knowledge
of Knight and bishop checkmate but that
did not quite happen
um he managed to consolidates I tried to
activate my king
but yeah the the two Bishops combined
with the Nitro black are just
overpowering I lost another pawn
and I tried to set up one last trick
after Knight D6 I took on Asics uh given
up a pawn was overworked but winning a
pawn like this was just not enough I
actually lost the pawn
um very soon because I have no good way
to defend my b-pawn
uh so I took on C6 he takes back and
things are just simplifying very much in
Black's favor
um yeah again my Hope was to somehow
force a knight in Bishop checkmates but
uh that did not happen and after Knight
G7 blocks winning H Pawn and I threw in
the towel
and yeah it was a tough game
um of course losing to a lower rated
opponent does sting a little bit but I
do want to give my opponent like huge
kudos for finding just a series of
incredibly strong moves from well I
thought it was a very difficult position
and uh yeah just going back we can see
I'll show the um the engine analysis
just very briefly we can see that light
was plus two apparently I had to play
Queen B3 it was a more accurate move
than Bishop F1 presume will be
preventing Queen A4 and uh not having to
worry about this uh eventual Rook C2
idea but after Bishop F1 I basically
lost my whole advantage and then after a
bishop H3
I lost
the quality and uh already 96 is a
nearly winning position for black and I
didn't realize it during the game just
how bad it was
um and yeah like he he found just a lot
of just really strong moves and I think
from this point forward he did not let
his Advantage slip
so
as a tough lesson I think a lot of
lessons to take away from this game
um having a solid and comfortable
position out of the opening is not
enough to win and even when things are
comfortable it just takes a lot of
efforts to actually convert the
advantage and be aware of the opponent's
counter play
so I am half out of two not the best
start to the tournament but there are
eight more rounds to go I have about 19
hours until the next round I'm not sure
if I'll be able to post this before the
next round but just be sure to check all
the links in the video description I'll
leave links to the live broadcast uh
nichas and chess.com and the official
tournament website with pairings and
standings and of course my twitch
Channel where Jonathan trance has been
doing commentary for my game so far
so do stay tuned for more Recaps and
hopefully I'll be able to provide some
happier results but until then thanks
for watching and I'll see you guys soon